if you've always wanted to know more
about this legendary Harry Potter
character here's your chance get
comfortable because we're explaining
Dumbledore's long backstory amazing
talents and complicated timeline
throughout the beloved series Albus
Percival Wulfric Brian Dumbledore was
born in 1881 to Percival and Kendra
Dumbledore the family resided in
Godric's Hollow the ancestral home of
Godric Gryffindor where the Potter
family would later live and die as well
considered to be one of the greatest and
most powerful wizards in history
Dumbledore was known for his distinctive
long white beard half moon glasses and
whimsical attitude when fans first meet
him he's cracking jokes about auspicious
cars and offering up lemon drop candies
like a kindly grandfather ah Bertie
Botts every flavour beans that was most
unfortunate in my youth to come across
as vomit flavored one throughout Harry's
relationship with a man who would become
both his professor and mentor Dumbledore
can often be inscrutable funny and
intentionally vague
however Harry's relationship with that
elderly wizard is Curt unexpectedly
short at the end of Harry Potter and the
half-blood Prince when Dumbledore is
killed at the hands of server a Snape
Harry watches helpless as one of his
only parental figures pulls to his death
in June of 1997 and though there's more
at play here than he realizes
Harry can't help but be horrified in the
moments at the time of his death
Dumbledore was a whopping 116 years old
for the most part he seemed to be in
great health throughout the series even
at such an advanced age and had he not
sought to use the resurrection stone
which a young Tom Riddle added cursed
after transforming it into one of his
seven Horcruxes it's easy to surmise
that Dumbledore could have gone on to
live quite a bit longer before he
ascended to his future glory Dumbledore
was one of the many new eleven-year-old
arrivals a Hogwarts School of Witchcraft
and Wizardry like other first-year
students he participated in the school's
time-honored sorting ceremony which with
the help of an enchanted saucing hats
students are placed into one of four
different factions Gryffindor Slytherin
hufflepuff and ravenclaw typically brave
students a place in Gryffindor cunning
kids end up in Slytherin hard-workers
had two Hufflepuff and the smartest find
their home in Ravenclaw though
Dumbledore subtly possesses traits from
every house it's no surprise that he
would wind up
gryffindor though it is possible he was
a serious ravenclaw contender however
the most controversial element of
Dumbledore's youth is undoubtedly his
close personal relationship with Gellert
Grindelwald that particular story isn't
revealed until deathly hallows when
following Dumbledore's death a tell-all
book about his life is published by
toxic reporter rita skeeter though she
does take some liberties when it comes
to Dumbledore the truth is he really was
friends of Grindelwald it was a fact
that would cast a rare negative light on
the Wizards life and legacy in the wake
of Dumbledore's passing a much is
written about the venerated wizard
including a touching personal a bit too
Airy penned by his Hogwarts classmate
and longtime friend Alphaeus Doge for
the Wizarding newspaper The Daily
Prophet in its he knows that he planned
to travel the world alongside Dumbledore
after their graduation but the death of
Dumbledore's mother halted those plans
alongside his brother Aberforth
Dumbledore's left to care for their
younger sister Ariana that's a child
Ariana had suffered an attack at the
hands of some boys who lived near
Godric's Hollow it left her with the
inability to control her magic which
would then manifest as random and often
dangerous outbursts when the father
attacked the boys in Italian he was sent
away to Azkaban and their mother was
left to manage ariana alone eventually
Kendra became the victim of her
daughter's misplaced magic and Albus and
Aberforth were put in charge of a sweet
yet inadvertently dangerous girl the
family's choice to keep Ariana hidden
led to nasty rumors with many believing
that ariana was a squib a child with no
magical abilities born to a family of
wizards and that the proud Dumbledore's
were too ashamed of her to allow her out
in public the less famous Dumbledore
brother Aberforth resented his brother
and that's he tells Harry in the Deathly
Hollows he always considered Albus to be
higher mighty about his considerable
intellect and talent
my brother sacrificed many things mr.
Potter on his journey to find power as
Ariana's main care taker Aberforth
watched as his brother made extravagant
plans that had nothing to do with his
family but it was Albus his friendship
with the Grindelwald that created the
biggest rift between the siblings when
Grindelwald moved to Godric's Hollow as
a teenager to live with his aunt but the
older buckshots
author of the famous a history of magic
and friend to Harry Potter's parents
before their deaths in 1981 he and
Dumbledore struck up a fast friendship
plotting ways to make the Wizarding
World
but when Aberforth butted heads with
Grindelwald the latter casts the
Cruciatus curse and unforgivable curse
that causes unbelievable pain on the
former as a dude
ariana got in the middle of the fight
only to be killed by a stray spell in
the aftermath of Ariana's tragic death
Dumbledore's need for power holy abated
as he later told Harry he didn't think
he should be trusted in such a way after
his friendship with Grindelwald ruined
his family turning down repeated offers
to take the ultimate seat of power and
become minister of magic
Dumbledore turned instead to his true
love teaching as one of the most
intelligent and learned Wizards in
history it makes sense that Dumbledore
would want to share his wisdom with
young witches and wizards and he
returned to teach both defense against
the dark arts and Transfiguration
throughout his early 10 year at Hogwarts
as a Transfiguration teacher
Dumbledore encountered a curious young
boy named Tom Riddle whom he immediately
recognized as a talented yet foreboding
presence of course that student would
grow up to become none other than Lord
Voldemort's Dumbledore's greatest
adversary outside of Grindelwald did you
know sir then did I know I just met the
most dangerous Dark Wizard of all time
No before he fully became Voldemort many
who knew Tom Riddle saw him as a bright
kind and thoughtful students he was
simply desperate to prove himself
Dumbledore however knew riddle was
capable of great cruelty and
vindictiveness from an early age and was
always wary of the young wizard
immediately after riddle graduated he
applied for the post of Defense Against
the Dark Arts professor but was turned
down and when he tried a second time
Dumbledore rebuffed him yet again riddle
was already well on his way to becoming
Lord Voldemort by the time he asked
Dumbledore for a job it already created
at least one if not more of his soul
carrying Horcruxes which can only be
crafted by committing the ultimate sin
taking another's life Tom told
Dumbledore that he wanted to pass his
storied knowledge under Hogwarts
students but it was obvious that
Dumbledore had some idea of the kind of
magic that future Dark Lord would wind
up teaching and he refused in that
moment Dumbledore sealed the fate of the
entire position as he later pointed out
to Harry Voldemort jinx the post and no
defense against the dark arts professor
ever stayed for more than one year after
that fateful meeting
Dumbledore's teenage friendship with
Grindelwald turned out to be a little
more than he had
Argand for initially the two became
involved in a secret relationship though
JK Rowling has explained that Dumbledore
strong feelings may not have been fully
reciprocated when she announced after
the books ended that Dumbledore was
actually gay the great tragedy of
Dumbledore sexuality is that as far as
Rowling has revealed so far he seemingly
never got the chance to live his truth
and express himself in any sort of
healthy relationship though he and
Grindelwald carried on a very physical
affair Dumbledore was eventually forced
to face the man he loved and defeat him
once and for all you are the only wizard
who is equal I need you to fight him in
the 1940s a Dumbledore dog Grindelwald
in an epic battle ending a decades-long
Wizarding war and taking down a man who
turned out to be the penultimate face of
evil second only to Voldemort in the
wake of Grindal Volt's defeat Dumbledore
ascended to the position of headmaster
at Hogwarts Rowling later explained he
lost his moral compass completely when
he fell in love and I think subsequently
became very mistrustful of his own
judgment in those matters so became
quite asexual he led his syllabus and a
bookish life Aberforth may have been
angry at his brother believing that he
never truly cared about what happened to
his mother and sister or about the rift
between the two siblings but that
couldn't have been further from the
truth
beyond this during an important Ministry
of Magic job and flying relatively under
the radar
Dumbledore lived with Momentis regrets
about his loved ones regret is my
constant companion become yours drawing
sorceress stone when Harry discovers the
mirror of Erised ed a magical object
that shows its users their deepest
desire
yes Dumbledore the elder wizard sees in
the mirror and Dumbledore responds that
he sees socks a gift he always wants for
Christmas how he gets the feeling that
Dumbledore might not have been telling
the truth later when the two were trying
to procure a Voldemort's Horcruxes from
a secret cave Dumbledore drinks a potion
to an earth the horrible magical item
and screams for hurry to hurt him rather
than them as Harry later tells Aberforth
it was clear that Dumbledore was a
haunted man and that then he was crying
out for was his lost family despite the
fact that he pathologically avoided
gaining too much power
Dumbledore did allow himself to buy into
a single myth and take control of one of
the most magically powerful artifacts of
all time
in the final installment of the series
Harry Ron and Hermione learn about the
eponymous of Deathly Hollows made up of
the invisibility cloak the resurrection
stone and the Elder Wand Harry is only
invisibility cloak all among by the
resurrection stone in the Elder Wand
belonged to another specifically to
Dumbledore in order to try and bring his
family back Dumbledore tried to break
into a curse Ring of Voldemort's to
retrieve the stone and round up
afflicted with a fatal curse but he
maintained possession of the Elder Wand
after his door with Grindelwald since he
knew that Voldemort would stop at
nothing to get the world's most powerful
wand he arranged his own death that
Snape's hands for nesting the ownership
of the wand until it would fall to Draco
Malfoy a young boy tasked to killed
Dumbledore by Voldemort himself in the
end how he ends up the master of the
wand but it's still a pretty incredible
feat on Dumbledore's path and has only
hide the ones from evil for so long but
to ensure that it would never truly work
for Voldemort's purposes throughout the
series Dumbledore is a wisest and sages
character of all advising everybody on
everything from deep and powerful magic
to matters of the heart beyond his
kindness and generosity the wizard was
also imbued with particular magical
skill and his list of accomplishments
and talents seems never-ending skill
documents and the gentleman's Dumbledore
had the ability to both see into other's
minds and block others from seeing into
his own he could conjure everlasting a
breathy and fire and make himself
invisible without a magical cloak and he
was a master at all magical doors
fighting everyone from Grendel Valle to
Voldemort Dumbledore was also an
accomplished Alchemist who helped create
the Sorcerer's Stone with Nicolas Flamel
which can turn any item to gold and
promises eternal life he discovered all
12 uses for Dragon's Blood and on top of
all of its he spoke multiple languages
including myrrh michw though it's never
known how or why he learned it finally
and most importantly of all his
knowledge of and belief in the power of
love as it pertains to magic and
protection was unparalleled in fact it
was just that knowledge and belief that
eventually helped Harry topple
Voldemort's do not pity the dead Harry
pretty the living and above all all
those who live without love
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos but
your favorite stuff are coming soon
subscribe to our YouTube channel and to
the pal so you don't miss a single one
[Music]